Have you ever stopped to think that it's possible
to lose a lot of blood -- like a LOT -- and
not die? Or is that just me… am I weird…
Meh! Well, we can live with about ⅔ of our
blood lost! It’s nuts. Let’s break it
down.
On average — and this of course varies from
person to person based on height and weight
— an adult human has somewhere between 1.2
to 1.5 gallons of blood circulating in their
body at any given time.
And even though we say “blood” like it’s
one thing, blood is actually made of four
things.
Plasma is the liquid that carries salts, electrolytes,
and blood cells around your body. Red blood
cells are the ones that carry oxygen, white
blood cells fight infection, and platelets
help us stop bleeding when we get a cut.
The interesting thing is that the parts that
make up blood don’t have the same lifespan.
Plasma is replenished as we eat and drink.Red
blood cells last about four months, white
blood cells turn over about every day, and
platelets last about ten days… and all those
cells are made predominantly in the bone marrow
controlled by hormones. The takeaway here
is that blood is always turning over.
So say you donate a pint of blood, which is
the standard amount. This is actually about
10 percent of your blood! The plasma will
be replenished almost immediately, and the
platelets and white blood cells pretty soon
after because the body makes those all the
time. But it takes days for a stem cell in
the bone marrow to become a functional red
blood cell, so it can take a few days or even
a week for your body to replenish all the
components of blood taken for the donation.
And with red blood cells taking the longest
to replenish while also having the vital function
of carrying life-giving oxygen to all our
organs, it’s this cell count doctors look
at when you lose blood. I talked to my dad,
Dr. Teitel, who is a haemotologist, about
what happens.
So how much blood can you lose before it becomes
fatal? Well, Dr. Dad says it depends on how
much you lose, but also how FAST
you
lose it.
The important thing
is haemoglobin.
Basically, says Dr. Dad, your body can adapt
to slow blood loss like it does to high altitude.
So the same way you can’t go from sea level
to the top of Everest in one go, you can’t
drastically change your blood volume and survive.
So it gets messy, literally, but at the end
of the day our bodies are sort of like a thermostat
when it comes to blood -- they’re excellent
at keeping everything at the right level so
we can go on living. Thanks, body!
And speaking of adapting, sort of, snake venom
isn't always bad right here. So what’s your
favourite blood fact? Let us know in the comments,
be sure to like this video and subscribe for
more Seeker